[Music]
Selena Gomez and The Weeknd are taking
their relationship to the next level
can't keep my hands to myself a source
tells ET the musical couple has moved in
together and are now calling a low-rise
luxury apartment building in New York's
Greenwich Village home but the source
adds the move is just temporary as
Selena is currently in New York filming
an untitled Woody Allen project check
out this photo of her unset Monday
sporting a tan trenchcoat light washed
skinny jeans and white sneakers
meanwhile the weekend is on tour the
source says the move is a big deal for
Selena who typically stays in hotels
when working remotely adding that while
LA is still her home Selena is
definitely immersing herself right into
the nitty gritty of New York according
to the source Selena and the weekend's
new pad features high ceilings and
his-and-hers vanities there's even a
steam shower and similar units have
rented for over $16,000 per month
I'm a really happy place it's been good
[Music]
Oh